The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high-quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
Due to technical difficulties,
only a portion of lecture one
is available for viewing.
PROFESSOR: Welcome to Teaching
College-Level Science and
engineering.
The title contains the word
teaching, which may spark some
questions in your mind.
For example, is teaching
just an art?
Or is it something that's just
something you're born with?
In which case, either you have
it or you don't have it.
Well, obviously, I don't believe
that, or I wouldn't be
teaching a course on it.
What would be the point?
Or is it purely a science
where there's a set of
equations and procedures to
learn, and then all of a
sudden, you'll be an
excellent teacher?
Well, actually, it's neither.
And it's both.
It's things that we're all born
with, on the one hand.
And there're also procedures
and techniques and ways of
thinking that will improve
how you teach and
that we can all learn.
So it's a happy mix,
my favorite mix,
an art and a science.
So another example that's
an art and the
science is book design.
So compared to, for example,
just pure art--
painting, say modern
painting--
very unconstrained, versus say
biology procedures in the
laboratory, very, very
closely specified.
It's somewhere in between.
There's an art--
all the arts of color, space--
but they all have to be used
together to achieve a
particular purpose.
So again, in there, there's
some beautifully designed
books and some not so
beautifully designed books.
And there're principles behind
that that we can use to design
good books.
And similarly, there are
principles we can use to
design good teaching.
So the whole point of this
semester is to design good
teaching and how you do that.
And rather than me give you a
big long theory about it,
because actually there isn't
really theory so much in the
equivalent to, say, Einstein's
theory of relativity.
But there's principles
to learn.
The best way to learn those
principles is with an example.
So what we're going to do today
is I'm going to do an
example of teaching with you.
We're going to do a sort of
maybe slightly sped-up version
of what we would normally do,
say, if we were actually using
this example in a class.
Then we're going to analyze
why it was done that way.
And from that analysis, general
principles of teaching
will come out that
will be addressed
throughout the semester.
And they'll be addressed
in the context
of particular tasks.
Like for example, how to make
slides that are useful for
teaching, how to use a
blackboard, how to teach
equations, how to
design a whole
course, how to make problems.
So all of those tasks will be
the week by week subjects.
And in each task, all of the
principles that we're going to
talk about now will show
up in those tasks.
And you'll see the principles
illustrated repeatedly.
OK, so the problem--
one of my favorites.
So these are two cones.
One has twice the dimensions
of the other cone.
So let me show you how
I made the cones.
So I printed out a circle and
just cut out one quarter of
the circle.
And then I taped this
edge to that edge.
Or in mathematician speak, I
identified the edges, which
now I know means I taped
the edges together.
And then you get a
cone, like that.
So this cone and the other cone
were cut out of the same
sheet of paper except this
one has twice the linear
dimensions in its circle.
So I think this circle was 7
centimeters in radius, and
this is 3 and 1/2 centimeters
in radius.
So other than that,
they're the same.
And the question is,
which one has the
higher terminal velocity?
Or are they about comparable?
So in particular, the
question is this.
So I'm going to drop them.
And the question is, what's
their ratio of their terminal
velocities?
So the ratio of the big cone's
terminal velocity to the small
cone's terminal velocity
is equal to what.
And you get choices
along this axis.
So here is--
OK, so those are the five
regions to choose from.
So you have five choices
for the ratio,
basically roughly 1/4.
This is some range here, because
nothing's exact.
And we're certainly not going
to do an exact experiment.
Roughly 1/2, roughly 1, roughly
2, or roughly 4.
So does everyone understand
the question?
Because you're going to get
to try it yourself.
Question about the question?
AUDIENCE: If you could restate
it-- actually, there was a
sign-up sheet going around
which distracted me.
So I sort of lost the--
PROFESSOR: Sure.
Could I restate the question?
No problem.
So I'm going to drop them,
just like this.
No tricks--
I'm not going to flip this
one around or anything.
And the question is,
what's the ratio of
their terminal speed?
So right away, as soon as you
let go of them, they come to a
steady speed, which is their
terminal velocity.
And the question is, how do the
terminal speeds of the big
one and the small one differ?
OK, so in particular, the
question is, what's the ratio?
And there's five choices
for them.
Does that help?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
So what were the dimension
of them again?
PROFESSOR: So this guy is--
he was cut out of a circle who
was 7 centimeters in radius.
And this guy was cut out of
a circle who was 3 and 1/2
centimeters in radius.
And then I was also very
careful to use--
let's see.
Did I do this right?
Yeah, I used to half the with of
tape on the small guy as I
did on the big guy, just to get
it really very perfectly
scale invariant.
OK any questions about
the question?
OK, so think to yourself for
about 30 seconds or so, just
to induct yourself
into the problem.
And then we'll take a vote.
And then you'll have a chance to
discuss it with each other.
OK, let's just take a vote.
So I recognize I haven't given
you at all enough time to come
up with an exact answer or
calculate everything.
And that's by design.
So let's just get
a straw poll.
And then you'll have a chance
to argue with your
neighbor about it.
So who votes for 1/4,
which is that the--
so let's see--
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6.
OK, 6.
Who votes for 1/2?
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7--
12.
Who votes for C?
22.
Who votes for D?
No takers.
No takers for D. OK,
how about E?
OK.
So now find a neighbor or two,
one or two neighbors.
Introduce yourself
to your neighbor.
And also, by the way, unless
you're taking notes on your
laptop and really insist on
doing that, if you could close
your laptop, that would be very
helpful for the purpose
of discussion in this
whole course.
So find a neighbor or two.
Introduce yourself.
You'll be getting a chance to
meet graduate students from
across the institute.
This is a great opportunity.
And try to convince them of your
answer, especially if you
have a different answer.
Or if you happen to share an
answer, well, see if you can
figure out why you're
sure of it.
Or if you're not sure of it,
see if you can settle that.
OK, so discussion time.
And if you have any questions
that come up as you're
discussing, raise your hand.
And I'll come and wander over.
Meanwhile I also handed out
feedback sheets for the end of
the session, which I'll ask you
to just spend a minute on
at the end.
But you'll notice one of the
questions is, what's the most
confusing thing?
So if anything really confusing
comes up during the
whole session, you can just
put it right then.
You don't have to wait
till the end.
Or if there's something you
really liked or hated--
that's question two-- you can
put that whenever it happens
to come up.
But vote number two, and then
we'll take some reasons.
So 1/4?
1, 2, 3.
OK, 4.
1/2--
the halves don't have it.
Oh, no, there's 1.
Oh, there's 2.
OK great--
3, 4, 5, 6.
Equal?
OK, so that's about--
let's call it 30.
2?
And 4.
OK so thanks for the votes.
Let's take reasons
for any of them.
I'll take reasons for
any of them, and
I'll put them up here.
You don't even have to agree
with the reason.
It's just something you guys
discussed and thought maybe
was plausible.
AUDIENCE: C seems to
have [INAUDIBLE].
When you do this kind of
activities, there is always
some guys who have
seen it before.
And he may choose to spoil it.
So I may want to know
what you would do in
that kind of situation.
PROFESSOR: So you're--
hm.
I'm not sure how
to phrase this.
Let me just take
other comments.
I'll come to it afterwards.
Other comments for any
of the reasons?
So again, it doesn't have to
be things you necessarily
believe, but things that
are plausible.
And that's actually more
instructive than what you
think is for sure right.
Because now you're trying to
figure out what might be true.
And you're expanding the
ways you're thinking.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: C, because they
have identical mass to
surface area ratio.
PROFESSOR: OK.
C, so mass to area ratio
is the same.
OK, can people think of
plausible reasons
against that argument?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: So I have no idea what
the actual formula is for
calculating it.
If there was a square in
there, then that would
[INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Right.
So I'll call this Not C. So
suppose the formula actually
depended on the square root
of A or square of A or
something like that.
It's, say, one chance out of
three that it has A to the
first power here.
It could have A to the
1/2 or A to the 2.
So could be m over A to the
k for k not equal to 1.
Others for or against C,
intuitive reasons, or for any
of the others?
So hopefully that's--
oh, yes.
Go ahead.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
The air resistance scales
with the area.
And the gravitational force
would normally scale with the
volume, [? except that it's ?]
in the surface, [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: OK, so let's see.
F drag proportional
to area and weight
proportional to area.
So that's an argument
for which choice?
AUDIENCE: For C.
PROFESSOR: For C, OK.
How do you know that the drag
scales with the area?
Maybe it scales with square
root of area.
Any arguments pro or con?
OK, yeah.
AUDIENCE: You could argue that
it scales with the area
because then you just break
it up into decimal pieces.
Each one has the same
force intensity.
PROFESSOR: OK, so for this,
let's say there's a thought
experiment of subdividing.
So I'll just note that as
Subdividing Thought
Experiment.
OK, yeah.
AUDIENCE: But then if you have
some weird shape, the air has
to flow through hitting some
pieces and then flow through
the rest of the pieces.
So that [INAUDIBLE]
may not work.
[INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: So it may depend
on the geometry.
So I'll put that up
here as Geometry.
What else might depend on?
For example, is air resistance,
say, always
proportional to area?
Hm.
Yep?
AUDIENCE: It could depend
on the material, surface
roughness or something.
PROFESSOR: OK, so it might
depend on the material.
And it certainly does, which is
actually one reason I was
very careful to construct
them out of the
same piece of paper.
So let me put this
is the material.
So the surface roughness.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Well, this may not be
relevant given how you said
you dropped them.
But it also might depend on
[? exactly how they ?] fall.
PROFESSOR: Right, OK, so whether
they fall vertically
or downward.
Yeah, that's true.
So it might depend on
the way I drop them.
So actually, yeah, to make us
not have to worry about that,
I'll just drop them
simultaneously pointing downwards.
Yeah, so the fall
configuration.
So there's all these
other variables.
So let's do the experiment.
Then I'll come back
to your question.
So let's do the experiment this
way, which is that I will
stand on the table and pray that
I have matching socks on,
which is sort of
80% these days.
It's increased.
And I will drop them on
the count of three.
Are they both about--
the points about
the same level?
They look sort of to me, but
my depth perception is
actually quite bad.
OK, so is that about equal?
OK, one, two, three.
Simultaneous.
OK, so there you
have choice C.
So now the interesting
consequence of that--
so what that shows is that
drag, in this case, is
proportional to area.
Now, it turns out that that's
not always the case.
So drag very often-- well, not
very often in everyday life.
But very easily, drag can
be proportional to size.
And you don't know ahead
of time which one
it's going to be.
So it turns out at slow speeds,
low Reynolds number,
this is true.
Turns out at high Reynolds
number, this is true.
And this is the simplest
experiment to show that.
So what this shows is that drag
is proportional to area.
So that with the same velocity,
the extra weight is
balanced by the extra drag
force by exactly 4 to 1.
And what that shows, now--
the consequence--
is that--
I'm going to replace the
proportional with a twiddle.
So it has an area in it.
So I'm just going to get
something with the
correct units now.
So it has an area in it.
And now you have left
to play with
density, speed, and viscosity.
So now let's actually construct
the drag force as a
result of that.
So we know by the experiment
it's proportional to area.
And now among these-- so this
here is the kinematic
viscosity, which is the one you
may be more familiar with
divided by rho, the density.
So we have to put some of these
guys in, some of these
guys in, and some of these guys
in, and make the units
come out as a force.
Well, one of them we
can do right away.
There's how many powers of
mass over on this side?
In a force-- just one.
And there's none here, yet.
So we need to get one power
of mass on this side.
Now, among all these
guys, which of them
have mass in them?
Not this one, because
you divided out.
Not velocity.
Only density, and density
has one power of mass.
So you have to put
one density.
Question.
AUDIENCE: I don't know what
the units of drag are.
PROFESSOR: So this is a force.
Good question.
So drag as a force.
So this is just newtons or mass,
length per time squared.
Does that help?
So it's just newtons,
in SI units.
Or in general, mass length per
time squared, so a mass times
an acceleration.
So now, we've matched
the units of mass.
But we haven't matched the
units of time yet.
So let's sort out the time.
There's no time here.
There's no time there.
There's t to the
minus 2 there.
Well, what can we
do about that?
We have to throw in some
v and some nu.
And the problem is we
don't know how much.
So the time doesn't
help us enough.
Turns out to make the time
and the length work, the
simultaneous constraint, the
only way to do it is that.
You make the same argument to
get the masses to match, the
lengths to match, and
the times to match.
This is the only way to do it.
So you don't have
any viscosity.
So actually, that's the simplest
experiment I know to
show that the drag
at high speed--
in other words, most flows are
actually high speed, high
Reynolds number-- is independent
of viscosity.
So it's rho av squared.
And that is a great result,
because it tells you all kinds
of stuff about everyday flows
in everyday life.
Like for example, why did people
reduce the speed limit
on the highway back in the
'70s to preserve gas?
Well, on the highway,
you're burning
gasoline to fight drag.
So if you reduce the speed,
you reduce the drag, you
reduce the amount of gasoline.
So in particular, if you reduce
the speed by 20%, you
reduce v squared by 40%, which
reduces the drag by 40%.
So you just decreased the gas
consumption by about 40%.
So you can see all these things
right away just from
this simple formula, which is
a immediate consequence of
this experiment.
Now, it turns out this--
how do you get that to work?
This is the low Reynolds
number limit.
You can't deduce it from
this experiment.
But if you know that this is
true, you can make the same
argument and figure out how the
drag force varies for low
Reynolds numbers.
OK, so now let's just check
whether this formula here that
we've deduced works at all.
So the follow-up question
is the following,
which is that I have--
one, two, three, four.
Here on this side, I have
four small cones.
They're all identical
to this small cone.
So I have one small cone, two
small cones, three small
cones, four small cones.
So I'm going to stack all
four small cones into
a thick small cone.
I'm going to race it against
one small cone.
So the question is, what's
the ratio of these
guys' terminal speeds?
So let's call it v4 and v1.
So v4--
OK, so what is the ratio of
their terminal speeds?
1/4, 1/2, 1, 2, or 4.
So talk to your neighbor
for just a minute.
I'll take a quick vote.
We will do the experiment.
OK, so let's take a vote.
And then we'll do
the experiment.
1/4--
no votes for 1/4 ratio.
Who votes for 1/2?
1?
2?
That's about 35.
4?
About 10.
So let's do the experiment.
One, two, three, four of them.
OK, so now let me drop
them like that.
Well, it's kind of hard
to tell it, isn't it?
So that was actually not a
well-designed experiment,
because you have to actually
get out a timer and decide
which one is going faster and
measure how long they took.
It would be nice if we had a
way that was just like the
other experiment.
What was nice about the other
experiment is when I dropped
them, you got the answer by
the fact that they hit
simultaneously.
So if we could make them hit
simultaneously, then that
would be nice.
Now, what do I have
to do to do that?
Well, I have to switch their
heights 4 to 1 or 2 to 1.
So let's try 4 to 1.
OK.
Is that sort of 4 to 1?
AUDIENCE: No.
PROFESSOR: No?
What do I have to do?
AUDIENCE: That has
to [? go-- ?]
PROFESSOR: This guy's
got to go down.
Yeah, see, this is where
my depth perception
really fails me.
So I only have monocular
vision.
I can see with both eyes, but
I don't binocular fuse, so I
can't tell depth.
AUDIENCE: Lower them both.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Oh, that's true.
AUDIENCE: Lower them both.
AUDIENCE: --corner
of the desk.
PROFESSOR: Pardon?
AUDIENCE: If you go in the
corner of the desk, then you
drop one on the desk and the
other one [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Oh, but then
you wouldn't be able
to see it so well.
So I want to do it on the desk
just so everyone can see.
OK, so if I lower them
both like this,
is that about right?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
[INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Lower?
Wow.
OK.
One, two, three, go.
No, not very simultaneous.
So let's try 2 to 1.
OK, I'll overcompensate
in my mind.
[? And it's ?]
probably about 2 to 1.
Is that about 2 to 1?
This one?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: [? Socks. ?]
Every time.
OK, 1, one thousand, 2, one
thousand, 3, one thousand.
Simultaneous.
And what's always amazing to me
is I always listen to the
class every time I do this.
And I never believe them
when they say it's
really 2 to 1 in height.
And I was like, OK, I'll
trust you guys.
And it always comes
out simultaneous.
So people haven't
lied to me yet.
So 2 to 1-- why 2?
Well, it had 4 times
the weight.
Same surface area, same
density-- you
couldn't change the air.
So you have to change the v.
How much do you change
the v by?
Factor of 2, because
you square it.
And you make up for the weight
increase by factor of 4.
So factor of 2.
So there you have an
application of it.
So now, let me get to your
question about what do you do
if someone tries to spoil
the experiment.
So the first thing to do is--
well, let me say what
were my reactions as
soon as you did that.
So my first reaction was, god
damn, why did he do that?
That was a really nasty
thing to do.
But then the second reaction
is-- whoop.
So now I've developed a habit,
which is a good habit to
learn, of just pausing before
you react to things.
Because you're much less
likely to cause bad
interactions if you pause.
So I paused to myself.
And I thought, there's actually
no point in saying
how annoyed I am right there.
And this will happen.
Suppose someone tries to
wreck your experiment.
You will be annoyed.
So it doesn't help you to
actually say how annoyed you
are and really make that
person feel terrible.
Because then what you've done
is you've polarized the
audience against yourself
besides making
that person feel bad.
So it's much better to do what
I did, which was say,
OK, tell you what.
I'll answer your
question later.
But also what I tried to do
is answer it implicitly.
I don't know if you noticed, but
what I did was when I came
to ask people, I figured, OK, so
people sort of have an idea
that it should be C just because
of somebody said,
well, I've seen the
demonstration before.
But what I wanted to know was
not why you think C is right
but why you think any of them
could be plausible.
So that was always part of the
question, but I emphasized
that part more.
And it has a good educational
purpose, which is that you're
trying to predict not just what
the quote "right answer"
is, but you're trying
to expand your
repertoire of options.
So you're actually making
yourself more creative by
thinking, what could
be plausible?
Because it's that way of
thinking that you're able to
use in other problems.
So I tried to turn it around a
bit and push it in a direction
that it would still be a useful
discussion for people.
OK, maybe not as useful as if
people didn't know ahead of
time that the answer is C,
but still a useful one.
Does that help answer
your question?
OK, so now what we've done--
we've actually gone through a
whole teaching example.
Yes, question.
AUDIENCE: So [INAUDIBLE]
talk about when you're writing
down the number of votes, if
you should leave them actually
like [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: I didn't see.
That's a good point.
AUDIENCE: And so that way, those
people would be like, oh
my God you didn't see me.
PROFESSOR: This is
a good point.
And I didn't.
And partly, it's because
the lighting in
this room is ghastly.
Partly my eyes are
not very good.
But all of those reasons support
exactly what you said,
which is that, especially if you
have a few people in the
class, you can always get
away with adding one.
And another thing you
can do is you can
always add one for yourself.
You think, well, I actually have
a plausible reason for
one of these.
Well, I'm going to vote
for one of them.
And every once in a while, you
vote for a correct answer--
you know, one out
of five times.
So the class learns.
But generally, you vote sort
of randomly just to give
support to the various
answers.
So you're right.
The question was, is it better
to not use zip ever?
And generally, it's true.
Unless you're dead sure no
one voted for anything.
And it's hard to see
in a large class.
That's one of the advantages
of the clickers.
There's disadvantages and
advantages of clickers.
And we can talk about them.
But you're right.
One way to mitigate that--
just throw in an extra vote.
Other questions?
So as I promised, what we're
going to do with
this example is now--
because this is actually not
an aerodynamics class.
You may be surprised
to find out now.
So you may have thought the
purpose was to actually learn
the air resistance formula.
If you do learn that, that's
really useful.
And I'd be really happy, because
it's a great result
which is very, very, very
hard to derive in pretty
much any other way.
You certainly can't derive
it from scratch from the
Navier-Stokes equations.
At least no one with current
mathematical knowledge knows
how to do that.
So experiment really is one of
the main ways of doing that.
So it's a great result
for that.
But what I want to use it for is
deconstructing it, looking
at the way it was taught
and why all the things
were done that way.
So in that discussion will come
out general principles
that we'll use throughout the
semester in all of our
examples of how to do teaching,
like for example,
how to make a lecture, how
to design a course.
So as always, those principles
are not very effective if I
just say, well, here are the
principles, and we're
going to use them.
It's much better if we actually
try them out in
example and see where did they
show up by constructing them.
So the question for the next
portion of this session is to
identify all of the teaching
elements in this.
So for example, what's
a teaching element?
Well, for example, there
was a vote or there
was a second vote.
So just deconstruct it to as
fine a granularity as seems
reasonable, and say, OK, this
was done, or this happened.
And then, why?
So two questions--
do a two-column table.
What and why?
And there'll be a pretty long
list because there was quite a
lot of things done.
So find a neighbor
or two again.
We'll discuss the
what and why.
And then I'll clump the
whys into principles.
So any questions about
that question?
ANNOUNCER: Due to technical
difficulties, the rest of
lecture one is unavailable.
What follows is a summary of the
material presented in the
remaining part of the lecture.
PROFESSOR: Think back to the
question about the cones--
which fell faster, or were they
the same speed, the big
cone or the small cone, and how
that question was asked.
What were all the elements
in the way the
question was asked?
What was discussed?
What did you do?
So it was scripted
very carefully.
And there were reasons for the
elements of the script.
So we've had a chance
to think about that.
And let me list many of these
scripting elements and their
reasons for them.
So on the left side, I'll
list the elements.
For example, there was
lots of interaction.
You were talking
to each other.
You were asking questions.
In fact, you weren't just
asking questions.
You were voting.
So twice you voted.
So voting twice, discussing.
So what are the reasons
for that?
What are the educational
principles behind designing a
question that allows lots
of interaction, voting,
discussing?
Well, first of all--
the why--
it gives the teacher, it gives
me, an idea of how the class
is thinking.
If, for example, I ask a
question, and in the first
vote almost everyone gets it
right, I know, OK, everyone
pretty much understands this
idea or this concept.
I can spend very little extra
time on it and move on to
something that may be more
confusing or more problematic.
Whereas if most people get it
wrong, I know, OK, either the
book was confusing or what I
explained already was confusing.
And we need to spend more time
discussing the core idea here.
So it gives me instant
feedback about
where the class is.
I don't have to wait till the
end of the term to find out on
the final exam, oh, no
one understood that.
I know right there when
I have a chance to do
something about it.
The voting also has
another benefit.
So the first benefit
is it tells me.
Also, it makes this students
form a public commitment.
And that public commitment has
a strong benefit, which is
that the students become much
more involved in learning what
the outcome of the
discussion is.
Because they've actually made
a public commitment to one
choice or another choice.
So it increases the level
of engagement.
Similarly, it creates tension.
People want to know what's
going to happen.
So when the demonstration
is actually done--
the final decider is
the experiment--
everyone is paying very,
very close attention.
So I'll say not just tension,
but I'll say it creates
dramatic tension.
Furthermore, the chance for lots
of interaction increases
the amount of interaction
in the whole class.
For example, students will ask
questions much more easily if
they've already had a chance
to discuss their ideas in
small groups.
So that's one set of elements
and the educational reasons
for building those in to how one
asks questions in class.
Another one is that I used a
physical object, in an actual
demonstration, so these cones.
And the physical object
is also cheap.
Anyone can make those.
You just cut circles out of
paper, cut a quarter away, and
tape it together.
You have a cone.
What are the benefits of that?
Well, first, it's much more
convincing than if I just do a
derivation from the
Navier-Stokes equations or
however one gets
to the result.
And say, OK, well, therefore
the drag is proportional to
the square of the speed.
Or therefore, they all fall
at the same speed
whatever their size.
If I just say that, or even if
I prove it with equations,
that's not nearly as convincing
as seeing it
actually happen.
And that's where in terms of
being convincing, it's also
important that the demonstration
be cheap.
If, for example, to see it
actually happen requires
$100,000 of equipment--
well, who knows what happens in
that $100,000 of equipment
and sensors and test devices
and whatnot.
Whereas if it's a cheap piece
of paper you can cut out for
$0.02, well, then anyone can
try it themself, too.
And it's not so mediated by
lots of sensory devices.
It's much more immediate.
It's much more convincing.
So I'll say here in
parentheses, a
cheap physical object--
ideally, if possible.
Furthermore, the physical object
actually connects the
mathematical and physical and
engineering ideas to the
physical world.
In the end, we want to try to
understand how the world
works, maybe put it
back together
in ways of our choosing.
So purely living in the
formal world, we're
living in the clouds.
By bringing in a physical
object, we actually put our
feet on the ground as well.
Another part of the
demonstration of the script
was various things that might
have seemed extraneous.
For example, I mentioned that
I hope my socks were matched
well when I stood
on the table.
I also discussed--
when I was standing on the
table, I said, OK, I need the
class's help here because I
don't have depth perception.
So I can't tell when
I'm dropping them--
when I was dropping one cone
versus four cones, I can't
tell when I've got this one
twice as high as this one.
And so you need to tell me.
So I talked about my failing
in the depth perception
department.
So both of these might
seem extraneous to
engineering and science.
But actually, they have a sound
educational reason.
So the socks joke-- well, that
makes the teacher seem much
more human.
Similarly, for the lack
of depth perception--
oh, well, the teacher
has flaws, too.
They're not this perfect person
who seems to know
everything.
And in fact, that one,
specifically because I didn't
have depth perception, I needed
the help of the class.
So that, again, is an excuse
to involve the whole class.
So no depth perception makes
a teacher human is also an
excuse for more engagement.
And related to discussing
another element of the script,
I want to amplify this one
up there, the discussing.
And I'll put it back
down here.
The discussion happened first
by yourself, then in a small
group, and then in the whole
class together where people
were suggesting reasons.
So I'll say discussions
at several scales--
self, group, and class.
So what's the educational
purpose of that?
Well, I mentioned one purpose
up there, which is it
increases questions.
And that's certainly true.
Another one is by allowing
people to think for themselves
first, you're giving space for
what's called the introverts.
Some people like lots of time
to think for themselves, and
only then do they want to
share with other people.
Because otherwise, their
thoughts get derailed by what
everybody else is saying.
Some people don't know what
they're thinking till they
talk to other people.
Let's call them the
extroverts.
So by allowing space for self
talk and group talk, you're
teaching to the introverts
and the extroverts.
So you're matching to the
learning styles of different
students in the class.
And then by scaling it up slowly
from self to group to
class, you make it safe.
You make it not a huge
transition to start to go to
the next stage.
Whereas if I just ask the
question of the class, OK,
whole class, now, you tell me
what you think about this
question and I skipped these
parts, only the usual suspects
would be offering
me ideas here.
The people who always raise
their hand-- maybe they sit in
the front row.
Whereas by allowing people to
think for themselves, then
discuss in a group the ideas
that they thought for
themselves, check out what
they've done there.
If they still think they don't
understand something and no
one in the group understood it,
then they feel safe asking
the whole class.
We're actually building
a bridge for people to
participate in the
large group.
So again, that point's
up there.
But it's so important I'm
putting it down here, too.
So I'll call it builds a
bridge to collective
participation.
And that participation can be
people contributing ideas or
questions which are
themselves ideas.
Another feature of how the whole
thing was done was that
I walked around a fair amount.
I used a lot of the space.
For example, even some of
the vertical space,
standing on the table.
Moving over here, moving over
there to make sure I heard the
question from that side
of the class.
So filling the lecture space.
Well, what's the educational
reason for that?
Well, in a way it's the opposite
of the socks joke.
In one way, it's the opposite.
In another way, it's the same.
It's showing that the teacher is
human and that teaching is
a human activity.
This is what actors
do on stage.
The stage, the whole stage
is there for a reason.
And the actors will
use all of it.
They won't just stand in the
middle the whole time, except
for rare comedy monologues
or monologues.
But otherwise, all the
pieces of the stage
are there for a reason.
And the actors use it.
They make that space
their own space.
They fill the lecture
room space.
So as a teacher, you want to
do that because that shows
that this is your space.
You're comfortable there.
And it increases your
credibility with the students.
And similar to this, it brings
in students from all parts of
the classroom, especially
if it's a big classroom.
They all feel somehow connected
to what's going on.
Because you haven't just stood
in one corner of the room or
just paid attention to one
section of the class.
So in one way, it's the opposite
of the socks joke.
Because in that way, the
teacher is being a bit
self-deprecating.
Here, the lecturer is acting
very confident
by filling the space.
But in another way,
it's the same.
They're both playing on the
human part of teaching, which
is inescapable.
And if it's neglected, the
teaching falls flat.
And finally, there was one other
point which may seem
like a mechanical point.
But it's so useful that
I'll put it here, too.
And I'll write it
with big chalk.
Point is, I wrote everything on
the board using big chalk.
And why is that important?
Well, in a small classroom of
maybe 10 or 15 people, it
probably doesn't matter.
Everyone can read everything.
But if it's at all a large
classroom, people can't read
the writing way in the back.
By using big chalk,
you increase the
signal to noise ratio.
Now, that may not seem
so important when
you first think about.
The reason being is
that you already
know what you're writing.
So even if you see really thin
lines, something that's not
very clearly written, you still
know what it should say.
And you just read
it correctly.
But the students, on
the other hand--
they don't have the knowledge
that you have.
So they can't error-correct
any--
fill in the missing
gaps in the lines.
They need as much signal as
possible to really copy down
anything correctly, to make sure
that they're not adding
noise onto the signal that
you're trying to get across.
So in some ways, a small point,
but in other ways, an
important point.
Because if you don't do it,
you'll throw away most of your
other benefits because the
students will actually be
incorporating wrong information,
just errors, just
by mistake without
even realizing.
And the big chalk can actually
minimize that.
So just a mechanical point.
I always keep pieces of big
chalk in my backpack.
And wherever I happen to be
teaching, I can always pull
them out and use them.
Because you will find many
classrooms only have standard
chalk provided.
And the big chalk is something
you have to do yourself.
So just carry a few pieces
with you as you need.
So those are some of
the many scripting
elements in this example.
And you'll see a similar
example in a subsequent
lecture, in the lecture on
teaching interactively, which
is lecture six.
And you'll see some of these
points come up again and some
of these reasons discussed again
in a different example.
So you'll have two different
engineering examples, but done
in a similar way.
And you can see the scripting
elements and how they're
different and how they're the
same in both examples.
And see which ones you can
use in your own teaching.
So now, from these scripting
elements, we've extracted
teaching principles.
So credibility, signal
to noise ratio--
just remember those.
And then here's a bunch more.
I want to summarize them,
extract the main highlights
from that so that you can come
away with a clean picture of
what to watch for throughout
this semester.
So the main themes of
all of these are--
I would say they fall into
three categories.
Let me list them.
And then I'll break them
into three categories.
There's ways to promote
questions and discussion.
There's using stories
and humor.
And demos and, related to that,
things you can see--
visual examples.
And another pair of
environments--
credibility--
filling the lecture space--
and what I haven't directly said
yet as such, but we'll
call it a safe environment
for learning.
Creating a safe environment
That's what discussion at
several scales enables.
You create a safe environment
for people to think for
themselves, which then makes it
safe for them to think in a
group and discuss in group,
which then makes it safe for
them to think in
a whole class.
And so that makes safe bridge,
or two bridges, towards
collective participation.
So you've made a safe learning
and questioning environment.
Without this environment,
that won't happen.
So I put these in three columns
because I think they
fall into sort of three
pieces of the brain.
Questions and discussion--
sort of left brain.
Stories, humor, demos, and
visual-- that's right brain.
And credibility and a
safe environment--
I'll call that the emotional
brain, the amygdala.
Maybe you could put humor
over there, as well.
But the reason I put preamble
stories with the right brain
is it's a different kind of
learning than we think of when
we think of left-brain learning,
for example,
learning an analytical method
or the sequence
of steps or a recipe.
The learning that happens
from stories--
for example, about the
depth perception--
is a different kind.
It's kind of implicit
in a way, more
perceptive and the holistic.
So I put it in the right-brain
category.
So these are main themes in
creating your own classroom
teaching environment
and structuring how
you're going to teach.
And sure, there's also all
the questions of content.
But the reason I'm focusing on
all of these is that the
questions of content--
those have been done so
many, so many times.
You can find all the
content in a
gazillion different textbooks.
But the question is, how do
you integrate all of that
content into something
that makes for
good student learning?
And to do that, you need to take
account of all this, all
of these features, all these
aspects of the brain.
Because humans are
not computers.
And they can't just learn
by being programmed.
So from all these themes,
extract one giant theme, which
is that teaching is not
necessarily equal to learning.
Just standing up there and
teaching stuff is no guarantee
that students will learn it.
You need to pay attention to all
these features, all of the
human interaction to
make sure that
learning actually happens.
So that's, if anything,
the main theme.
Or phrased another way is that
meaning and knowledge must be
constructed by the learner.
And all these ideas up here,
these scripting elements,
these principles here are
ways to help that
construction happen.
Just telling them
doesn't do it.
You have to enable, facilitate,
that construction.
So what we're going to do for
the rest of the semester is
we're going to see these
principles, these principles,
these boiled-down themes, this
idea, this large idea--
the big idea of the entire
course exemplified in several
topics and areas that are
central to teaching science
and engineering and mathematics
at the college level.
And so the outline for
the rest of the
semester is as follows.
Today was lecture one.
And that was general principles
of teaching.
The next one will be on how
to teach equations.
Equations are central in all
science and mathematics and
engineering teaching.
So how do you teach
equations--
in other words, some of
the central content--
taking account of all
of these ideas?
Can you tell stories when
you teach equations?
How can you do that?
Well, we'll see.
The third lecture, the third
topic, is taking account of
students' misconceptions
and thereby
avoiding rote learning.
So you can see already where
some of the ideas that we've
been talking about here are
going to help here.
For example, having lots of
interaction and voting--
you find out where
the students are.
You'll find out if they have
funny ways of thinking about
stuff, maybe even predictable
ways, but ways that don't help
them actually solve problems
in the real world.
Well, how do you take
account of that?
There's one way right
there already.
Then designing homework
and exam problems.
And the fifth one is
course design.
How do you structure
a whole course?
Sixth one is teaching
interactively.
As an example, you've already
seen one example, which is
this kind of question.
Well, what are the general
principles behind such questions?
Can you make longer versions,
shorter ones?
Are there short ways of building
in interaction and
questions into learning?
Then what do you actually
do when you
come into the classroom?
Lecture planning and
performing--
how do you plan one lecture?
So this is the overall structure
of the whole course.
How do you plan and perform
one lecture?
Topic eight is teaching with
blackboards and slides.
So what are the advantages,
generally speaking, of
blackboards?
But what are situations where
slides are actually a really
helpful way to teach?
Slides meaning-- well,
it could be old-style
photographic slides, but
pre-prepared PDF files that
projected on the screen with an
LCD projector is generally
how it's done now.
And then how do you plan
blackboard work?
How do you construct slides so
that they're effective in
creating learning?
Ninth is sort of a result
of all these.
Well, if you're going to apply
all these principles, you'll
find yourself wanting to change
a lot about how the
course is done or how it
was done previously.
Well, what are the
barriers to that?
In particular, what are the
political barriers to
educational change?
So that by being aware of the
barriers, you're more able to
go around them, surmount them,
take account of them, plan for
doing it bit by bit by bit.
But eventually, hopefully
designing courses in ways that
you think are good for
promoting learning.
And then the 10th topic will
be a summary of everything,
using the examples we've done
the whole semester and a
chance for--
well, you'd ask questions
about the whole course.
OK, so that's the themes of
this entire semester of
teaching college-level science
and engineering
one topic at a time.
See everyone next week.
ANNOUNCER: Answers from lecture
two to questions
generated in lecture one.
PROFESSOR: What I'm going to
do is answer your questions
from last time on the
feedback sheets.
And I'll pass out a new set of
feedback sheets in a moment.
So I should say that
the questions
were, as always, excellent.
And I learned a lot by
thinking about them.
And I hope that you'll learn a
lot as you hear the results of
everyone else's questions
together, and that they
reflect concerns that maybe all
of you had at different
levels and the question that you
may have put down may not
have been all of
your concerns.
But collectively, hopefully
it captures most of them.
So I'll categorize the
first section of
questions as in reality.
I've typed in all
the questions.
I'm going to put them all
on the course website.
So you can see the questions.
And the answers will be here,
but you'll see the questions.
So in reality--
one question along that line
is, what about grading?
How do you actually implement
your grading policy as an
assistant professor in a
traditional department?
So my grading policy is
generally that, especially in
a pass/fail course, that the
grading be very minimal.
And in general, I think
that's a good
policy for grading overall.
And we can talk throughout the
semester about why and the
research behind that.
But how would you do that if
you're starting out new?
And the general rule is there's
no right answer.
For example, one solution--
it's not quite the answer
to the question--
is to take a position at a
place where you're the
department head.
So actually, I was offered a
teaching position like that
after I finished graduate
school.
And I thought long and
hard about it.
So I would have been the head
of the physics and math
department.
Now, that was the good side.
The bad side was that I was
the only member of both
departments.
And so on the one hand, I
was a department head.
But also, I was the only one
doing all the teaching.
And I would have only
me to boss around.
But in that situation, you do
have a huge amount of freedom.
And I could have done pretty
much whatever I wanted.
Now, I decided not to take that
position because I really
wasn't sure exactly what I
wanted to do in terms of
improving teaching.
And I thought, well, I really
need some more experience.
And I decided to
do a post-doc.
But that is one solution
to that problem.
It's not a very generalizable
solution.
There are not many positions
like that.
Another solution is to what I
call the Clark Kent solution.
So you go around as a
traditional faculty member, in
the Clark Kent outfit.
And then as soon as you
get tenure, foom,
off comes the suit.
And everyone realizes that oh,
actually, we hired someone
else completely, who actually
has all these interesting
ideas about teaching.
So that is generally legally
protected to some extent.
And you won't easily be fired,
although a colleague of mine
in Canada--
the university is trying
to fire him for
giving all As in a course.
So this does speak
to this question.
And it shows it is
a tricky issue.
So he believes-- and
I agree with him--
that grades generally just
produce obedient people.
One of their main functions is
to produce obedient people and
obedient students, rather than
students who love learning and
want to question.
So he wanted to teach one of his
courses-- he's a tenured
professor of physics.
He wanted to teach one of
his courses pass/fail.
And the university said, no.
By university regulations, that
course is graded only.
It has to be taught
with grades.
So he said, OK, fine.
On the first day of class, he
just told everyone they were
going to get an A+.
And according to the TA--
at least, this was then reported
in Canada's Globe and
Mail, their sort of
New York Times--
one of the teaching assistants
for the course said, yeah,
there were a few students who
took advantage of that fact.
But most actually did more work
and were very interested
in the material because of it.
So I would say, basically,
the thing was a success.
And that's generally what I
find, that the less emphasis
you put on grades--
especially at a place
like MIT--
the students' natural interest
in the material comes out.
And they're more and more
willing to work and learn.
And that produces long-lasting
learning.
Because they're doing it for
their own reasons, not because
you stood over them with
a grade and beat
them over the head.
So that was good.
The bad part is the university
basically said, well, you're
defying us, and you're going
against the purpose of the
university.
It's not really clear what the
purpose of the university is,
except maybe to produce
obedient people.
So they said, we're going to
institute proceedings for your
dismissal, to strip you of
your tenure and fire you,
which is a big step for
a tenured professor.
And meanwhile, they banned
him from campus.
So he's now not allowed on his
own university campus.
So then he came to campus for
a film screening, because he
runs a film series
on the campus.
So he came for that,
and the university
police arrested him.
So he was arrested for going
to his own university.
So then it got into the national
press in Canada,
which doesn't make the
university look so good.
But that's all by way of saying
that grading is a very
touchy issue with
universities.
And it's really not clear what
to do about it, because it's
so embedded in the system.
So I can't really offer you any
solutions to that question
except to say that it's a very
tricky negotiation and you
want to plan your activities
carefully.
If you're going to use a lighter
grading system, don't
do it all at once.
Get people around you to accept
it slowly, slowly.
Get students on your
side slowly.
Do things slowly.
Don't make any sudden moves
that get yourself fired.
Work with other people
of like minds.
Work together collectively.
So it's not a long-term
instant solution.
But any kind of social problem--
and I think grading
is a social problem--
doesn't have any instant
solutions.
So I wanted to answer that one
first, to basically tell you
that I don't have all the
answers to all the questions.
And I want to give you honest
answers as far as I know them.
OK, next question
about reality.
You've obviously done this
many times before.
As someone who needs to figure
out a logical order for the
material in addition to
balancing preparation time and
research, how do we juggle all
this in addition to simply
focusing on style?
So I want to dispel one
misconception was that last
time, I wasn't saying that you
can substitute style for
preparation and really
knowing the material.
It's really that I wanted to up
the importance that people
give to what people would call
style by saying that the way
you present, how you
present, is as
important as what you present.
In fact, it is, to some extent,
what you present.
If, for example, you're very
interested in the material,
and you present it in that way,
well, the students are
very naturally going to become
interested in the material.
As a test of this, you can
actually do little home
experiments on this principle.
So just go around to somebody.
You can do these little like
Candid Camera experiments.
Just go up to them and smile,
just like this, and then watch
what they do.
And a whole bunch of people
actually just smiled back at
me for no reason at all,
just because I smiled.
Now, not no reason at all.
It's because we're
social creatures.
We're programmed from millions
of years of evolution to pick
up other people's emotions
and ways of being.
So if you're enthusiastic about
the material, if you're
interested in it, and you
present it like it's
important, well, that actually
gets transmitted very
effectively and picked up
at the other end very
effectively.
So actually, that is part
of the content.
So I wouldn't say style is
separate from the content.
How you present, how you think
about the material is a
crucially important part
of the material.
Because that's when students are
going to be taking away.
And that's going to be affecting
how they think about
the material.
So it's not just focusing
on style--
that sort of gives it too
little importance.
Instead, yeah, how do you think
about all those issues
as well as surviving your
research grant?
And again, there I would
say the way to do
it is to start slow.
When you're an assistant
professor, you need to focus
on your research
to get tenure.
So focus on your research and
just try small teaching
experiments bit by bit.
Maybe in your first year, just
try putting in one small
conceptual question per
lecture or per week.
And if that goes OK, maybe
try longer ones.
Try more the next semester
or the next year.
So just try small things.
And as they work, grow them.
So that's one way, so you don't
have to sacrifice your
research and hose yourself.
So preparation time, as well--
so try to borrow notes from
colleagues.
Try to get as much from other
people as you can share.
Talent invents, genius steals.
So steal all the good
stuff around you.
So another one is how does this
work in the real world,
which is basically
the same thing.
So what I'm trying to do in this
class is show you general
principles that you can use
always to guide yourself in as
far as you want to go
in your teaching.
So now how far you go in your
particular situation depends
on your situation and how much
importance you put on doing
new teaching methods, new
experiments right then.
But I'm not saying you have to
start everything tomorrow,
like the first day you're a TA,
all of sudden throw out
all the regular stuff and
do everything like I'm
demonstrating now.
I'm showing you this as
examples to illustrate
principles for directions you
could go and for threads you
can pick up as you see best.
Syllabus and logistics
for this class--
any exams or problem sets?
Yeah, there's problem sets,
which you've seen one already.
No exams.
And so how are you
being evaluated?
Basically again, very
light touch.
Basically, just make a
reasonable effort on the
problem sets, and
you'll be fine.
I'm hoping basically that the
material's interesting enough
that you don't need a stick
beating you, saying, oh, you
must do this, you must do
that, you must do this.
It's not a required course.
People are taking it really
because they're interested.
So I'm not going to try to ruin
that with a whole bunch
of grading sticks.
Does it matter which subject
number we're assigned for?
No, and I don't even remember
what the subject numbers are.
I know 595, and there's
a whole bunch of them.
So I just write et cetera.
No, it doesn't matter,
as far as I know.
Could we have a break
after one hour?
Yeah, I think that's
a good idea.
So I'll give everyone like a
two- or three-minute break at
the hour just so you can
stand and get your
blood flowing again.
Biology examples-- can we
have biology examples?
A fair point--
so actually, today our first
example of equations is a
biology example, amazingly.
OK, so now, interactive
teaching-- how do you teach a
class interactively if
you have a lot of
material to get through?
This is a very interesting
question.
It comes up quite often.
And the answer is that
you don't get
through it in the lecture.
So the lecture is a terrible
place to get
through lots of material.
In fact, even the word "get
through," "cover"--
those all have the wrong
sense to them.
And so Victor Weisskopf, MIT
physics professor for many
years, he said-- and I think
it's a great saying--
instead of covering a lot of
material, I prefer to uncover
a few key ideas.
So uncover is the right verb.
Cover has the sense
of smother.
You can't see it anymore.
And that is what happens when
you cover too much material.
You want to uncover a few ideas
and let them bloom.
So a lecture is something that's
paced at human scale.
You talk at maybe 150
words a minute.
People can't write that fast.
They can write maybe
15 words a minute.
Reading is much faster.
Reading-- people can read 300,
maybe 400 words a minute.
So if you have lots of material
to get through, don't
fall into the trap of putting it
all on the blackboard or on
the overhead slides.
And we'll talk about that in
the session on making good
slides and using
the blackboard.
You want key ideas
to be there.
And you can leave lots of
the details for reading.
So that's one answer.
The other answer is that
sometimes, actually, I think
one of the fundamental problems
with so much teaching
is that we try to cover
too much material.
And one of the goals should be
for good teaching is to reduce
how much material one covers.
And there's a simple estimation
argument to show
why that's important.
The estimation argument is that
basically, suppose you
cover 100% of the material.
But because it's so much
material, students remember
only 10%, and really learn only
10%, which I think is
actually a reasonable
estimate.
Because they're just
so overloaded.
They have no time to make
connections, and it just
flitters away.
So 10% is all they retain.
Well, you could cover, say,
half the material.
And let's say that they still
don't remember everything,
even though you've done half.
Maybe they remember half of
that, because they have time
to struggle with it,
make connections.
So now, they're at half of half,
which is 25% retention
instead of 10%.
So that's a plausible model.
I'm not claiming those figures
are actually based on exact
research or anything.
But just a plausible model for
how reducing the amount of
stuff you cover can actually
increase learning.
So try to reduce material
when possible.
Almost always, there's
too much material.
OK, so again, how do
you pace lectures?
If you do too many demos and
you have less material,
advanced students
might get bored.
Actually, I find advanced
students are actually quite
interested in demos and
questions like this that we
used last time.
They want to really understand
what's going on.
And it's those kind of questions
that help them.
Covering lots of material--
again, they can read it in a
book much faster than you can
write it on the board.
So put it there.
Can these principles be
applied to upper-level
graduate classes?
For sure.
You can apply them all the way
from kindergarten through
graduate school because they're
really based on how
people think.
And they're based on common ways
that people perceive the
world and reason.
And that doesn't change--
I mean, life does change when
you become a graduate student.
But your whole way of
looking at the world
doesn't change that much.
So how do you deal with
classes where someone
dominates a discussion or the
class does not like to
participate?
Sort of two ends of
the same coin.
So what I like to do is if
someone keeps trying to say
stuff, I just say, oh, well,
actually I want everybody to
participate.
Could I hear from someone
I haven't heard from?
Just with a light touch.
You don't have to make
a big confrontation
in class about it.
If people don't like
to participate--
for example, suppose you ask
them to discuss with each
other and they don't.
So here's a trick I learned
actually from one of the
teaching seminars when I was in
England, which is that you
just turn your back.
And why do you do that?
Well, your back is not as
interesting as your front.
So students are actually taught
with, say, 12 years of
teaching to watch the teacher,
watch the teacher.
So one of the reluctances to
talk to each other is they're
watching the teacher, figuring
out what the
teacher's saying and doing.
Kind of like Clever Hans was
watching his trainer--
do I do more clips on my foot?
Is that 42?
6 times 7--
OK.
So students are actually taught,
basically, after 12
years of conditioning, do
that very automatically.
So you just have to break
that conditioning a bit.
If you just turn around, there's
nothing really that
interesting to look at,
unless you're maybe--
I don't know, some fashion model
or a GQ model, which I'm
not claiming to be.
So then the students will just
naturally be more likely to
talk to each other.
So you create the conditions
for that.
Another one--
and I often use this
trick, because it's
actually not a trick--
is sometimes I'm thirsty.
I just walk out of the room and
go get a drink of water.
So if it's an interesting enough
question, the students
will be talking to each
other about it.
And there's definitely not you
around there, watching them or
worrying them, for
them to focus on.
So that's one very
useful trick.
Generally, though, the overall
point is if the class doesn't
want to participate, you just
make it more and more safe to
participate.
You make sure you never
criticize people if they say
something that wasn't right.
You make sure you value
the wrong answers
and you explain why.
So all of the things I talked
about last time about safety
means you just have to do them
double if people aren't
participating.
How do you cope with a
variety of confidence
levels among students?
Also interesting.
So there, I find actually
that most
students aren't very confident.
They have different levels--
they're all generally much
lower than you think.
So they do have some different
levels, but it's generally
overall lower than you think.
So I spend more of my effort
making sure everyone feels
comfortable.
But again, if some students are
much more confident than
others, I try to mix up the
level of questions that I ask.
I ask some questions that I know
most people are not going
to be able to answer and some
questions that I know most
people will answer, just so
everyone has something.
And then on the problem
sets as well--
warm-up problems, regular
problems, really hard problems.
Like in Donald Knuth's
textbooks, the fifth set of,
kind of, problem at the end of
the chapters is unsolved
research problems.
And you never know.
Someone might actually
solve one of them.
So you can put something
for everyone in there.
What about the left brain?
Surely humor and demos can't
take you all the way.
Yeah, and that's true.
And so my answer to what about
the left brain is that the
left brain is what basically
most teaching has focused on
for most people's experience
over the last 15 or 16 years.
So I'm not saying, forget
about the left brain.
I'm saying that you basically
already know how to do the
left-brain side of teaching.
You have so many
models of that.
It is pretty much what we
think of as teaching.
You go up to the blackboard, and
you write down a series of
symbols one after
another, write
down a series of equations.
So you already have
models for that.
And we'll talk about how
to improve those.
But I'm not so worried
about that part.
What I'm worried about is
the neglected part.
So this you could think
of as the balance.
And then you'll be able to find
ways of integrating the
left brain.
And we'll do left-brain
things, equations.
But how do you integrate that
with all the quote "right
brain," the humor
and the demos?
How do you project confidence?
Fake it till you make it?
Yeah, that's basically right.
So one way is to actually make
sure your voice is clear.
So to do that, my piano teacher
in graduate school--
actually, she was a voice
teacher, as well.
She gave me a really useful
exercise, which is--
I do this for like 30 seconds
before I come to lecture.
So the exercise is you first
just close your lips.
And you mmm, you hum.
So we'll all do this together.
So you hum until you can feel
it vibrating in your nose.
That's step one.
So let's all do that together.
[HUMMING]
And if you have hay fever, you
can tell if you're doing it
right in the spring.
Because you'll dislodge
pollen grains and
you'll probably sneeze.
That's what I find
in the spring.
When I do that, I actually
start sneezing.
My theory is that I'm dislodging
pollen grains and
then I'm sneezing as
a result of them.
So mmm--
so now you've got a
resonance up here.
And now what you want to do is
with the same mmm sound, now
do it in the back of your teeth
with your mouth closed.
So you feel behind your teeth.
So we'll do step one
and then step two.
Mmm and then the teeth.
Mmm, teeth.
[HUMMING]
And you should feel
in your lips
vibrating, kind of tickling.
OK, so that's step two.
Step three is to then make the
vowel sound that is most
likely to make your mouth
resonate and be
really wide and open.
That's E. So we'll go hmm
and them mmm and eee.
OK, so nose--
[HUMMING]
lips--
eeeeeee.
OK, that's step three.
And then the final step is
you just add some words.
You modulate it with words.
All right, so I'll give
you a demonstration.
Then we'll do all
of it together.
[HUMMING]
Eeeee-- (SPEAKING ON SAME
NOTE) how are youuuuuu.
OK, so now, that sounds
a bit strange.
But you find after you
do that, your voice
is much more resonant.
Actually, I can hear
it right now.
To my own ears, my voice
sounds much more
resonant and clear.
So let's do that.
[HUMMING]
Eeeee--
(SPEAKING ON SAME NOTE)
how are youuuuuu.
So you'll find, actually, what
you've done is you've shifted
your voice from here, where it
just makes your throat tight,
to the front.
And just by doing that,
you will project.
And by projecting, you actually
sound more confident.
And you'll feel more
confident.
So that's one way.
But another way is to be
confident of your material.
And another way is, as you said
in the question, just
fake it till you make it.
Now, there's a few
more questions.
I'll answer some of them
on the website.
But I wanted to answer
one more.
How long did it take you to
become such a good teacher?
So I'm glad people think I'm a
good teacher, or at least one
person thinks so.
But there's a general answer
to that question, which is
actually going to be one of the
topics today, which is,
how do you become an
expert in anything?
And the first example I'm
going to show you-- it's
biology equations.
I'm going to use that.
And then after that, when I
talk about expertise in
general, not just in teaching,
and where that comes from.
And I'll show you the results
of some studies.
And then I'll come back
to that question.
And I'll hopefully
answer it then.
So those are I would say
2/3 of the questions.
The ones I haven't answered
I'll try to answer online.
And I'll pass out these
in just a moment.
But right now, what we're going
to do is we're going to
do the first example
of equations,
which is from biology.
Now, before I do that, any
questions that have occurred
to you meanwhile?
Did I create any
new questions?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Very germane, but if
this is P/D/F, are we supposed
to be registered as P/D/F?
PROFESSOR: I think
it's automatic.
I don't think there's any way
not to register as P/D/F.
AUDIENCE: OK, thank you.
PROFESSOR: So the question was,
if this is pass/fail, do
you have to specifically
register as that?
I don't think so.
I think it's automatic.
So yeah, basically, don't
worry about your grades.
Everyone's going to P.